hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website com2 they're going to be
starting our coverage of the 2016 Tata
Steel tournament one of the big
tournaments of the year starting the
year out right in the Netherlands 14
players nine of which are in the top
twenty in the world including our world
champion Magnus Carlsen 2016 is a big
year for tournaments we have the
candidates tournaments in at two months
and that's going to decide who actually
plagued Magnus Carlsen for the world
championship and so I'm gonna be
interested to see some of the players in
that tournament how they fare and we're
gonna look at one of those today Fabiana
Caruana twenty three old
italian-american Grandmaster he's gonna
be facing off in the Kandice tournament
in a couple months so he's gonna get the
party started today he's playing the
white pieces his opponent today's the
13th ranked player in the world
Grandmaster from you cane Pavel is Jonah
he is a very strong player 32 years old
so we're gonna go ahead and get started
Fabiana starts out with nice to f3 pawn
here to d5 upon up here to c4 pawn to e6
pawn here to d4 this is a kind of a
different variation getting to the
Queen's Gambit after Knight f3 or Knight
f6 Knight c3 we see pawn taking here on
c4 it's not super common nowadays for
black to take most of the games I cover
and watch black is usually playing in
the decline line set so kind of
refreshing to see the Queen's game it go
into an actual accepted line now after
pawn to e4 see the bishop come down here
to b4 and Fabiano it has a few options
here is main option is to play a bishop
here to g5 it says hey if you're gonna
pin down my knight I'm gonna go ahead
and pin down your knight as well this
kind of protects from the knight coming
here to e4 it's a huge pain for the
Knights coming here to e4 double attacks
this night here on c3 gonna go up upon a
material it's just you just don't want
to have to deal with it too much another
option is Queen here to see to that both
protects the night here on c3 and also
protects the pawn here on a4 Fabiano
says I'm not gonna do either of those
and he plays a bishop taking here on c4
and now the knight comes down here on e4
castle on the Kings side and this is
interesting because Fabiana is
essentially saying I'm gonna give you
that pawn I'm not even looking to get
that material back right away
I just feel like I'm so much
better essentially that I can play the
advantage of developing my pieces
towards the cinema board and that isn't
enough advantage for me to go ahead and
go on to win this game so pretty cool I
think to comment out the gates as the
white pieces to go that strong it is
very risky I think but that's kind of
the direction that he is going with now
black comes back with Knight to f6 I
really like just continue to take pieces
especially since you're up in material
you're playing such a strong player in
Caruana I would just go ahead and take
here after the pawn takes you know
Bishop takes here on c3 attacking the
rook rook here to b1 castle on the Kings
side this is going to be completely fine
for black because we step back he
decides to go ahead and play a little
bit safer play Knight back here to f6
now the bishop is gonna come here to g5
pinning down at this Knight - at the
Queen Castle on the King side Queen up
here to e2 just continuing developer
spaces already to finish his development
so if we look at kind of both sides of
the board black is up material by one
pond but White has all of his pieces
developed both of his knights
controlling the center of the board both
of his bishops very very active
controlling the light and the dark
squares pinning down this Knight the
rooks are connected the Queen's
controlling the central file efile and
black on the other side hasn't moved as
Queen Bishop Knight or rook over here on
the Queen sets we definitely is going to
be looking to kind of place somewhat
defensive whites and really needs to
continue to be aggressive if you're down
material you have to bet on the fact
that okay I have more active pieces I
have better development I can use that
to my advantage to maybe gain material
back get to checkmate something like
that black just needs to hold on make
sure white can't do any of that and so
we see pawn here to h6 Bishop back here
to h4 [ __ ] back here to e7 black
doesn't want to be too aggressive he
knows that if he can play good defense
he's definitely gonna be in this game
middle going into the late game who
cover here to a d1 just solidifying kind
of the central pawn here since it
doesn't have any pawns connected to it I
needs to make sure that it has major
minor pieces behind it protecting us who
can start to push forward on board
Knight here did d7 and that appeared to
e5 Knight over here to b6 Bishop back
here to d3 and this is
if you kind of look at and say what the
Queen could come here to D for this is
one of those moves that the grandmasters
not going to fall forward but every now
and then you'll see someone at a lower
level actually fall for this they feel
like you've kind of made a mistake but
if the Queen were to come here with the
D for all of a sudden Bishop here to h7
check and then the Queen's going to fall
it is a discovered attack on the Queen
right here we don't really see that
being taken here on from a grandmaster
is as good as Pavel but then it's gonna
come here to defy Bishop back here to g3
Bishop here to a d7 Knight up here to e4
so as we kind of look at it blacks doing
a really good job we don't see white
taking advantage of the fact too much
because there's no way for him to really
do that black he's just really solid on
defense so black has the advantage here
there's nothing he has to worry about as
far as threats right away and he is up
and material so Fabiano's gotta find a
way to kind of break through and use
kind of his advantage that he has
position wise or else he's going to go
down in this game bishop down here to a4
attacking the rook rook over here to see
one controlling the semi open file
that's fine as well Matt back here to d7
pawn appear to be three we're first
gonna see exchange here on e5 and then
the bishop is just going to come back
here to c6 nice little square just to
control the center of the board for the
light square Bishop rook over here to a
d1 pawn up here to a5 pawn here to a4
and then Queen here to e8 just wants to
make sure he's controlling protecting
the bishop here also wants to make sure
you can swing his rook over here to the
eights get involved into the action and
control discern the board since this D
file is completely open does not want to
have his Queen here instead wants to
make sure he has this his rook over here
on d8 so pawn up here to h4 Fabiano
decides he needs to start being a pretty
aggressive on board Luke over here to d8
and now pawn up here to h5 Knight over
here to b4 nice little outpost also
opens up the door for this rook to kind
of control this long open file we have
bishop back here to be one and this is
kind of a sneaky move since you have the
King castling over here
on GHC the pawn opened up here on h6
this light square bishop always poses
the threat that black has to worry about
just coming here to h7 or potentially
having a queen here on d3 or c to swing
into action so just another thing that
black kind of has to worry about but
this does open up the door for the roofs
to trade off if they want to we are
gonna see the King come over here to h8
just doesn't want to have to worry about
the bishop ever coming here to h7 so
that looks completely fine to me
Bishop appear to f4 opening up the door
later on if the pawn were to come to g6
kind of stopping any sort of threat then
this bishop can come over here take here
on aged six that's gonna be very very
good for white so just kind of it slowly
improving his position as Caruana
we have the rook over here to a g8
protecting the King a little bit more
Bishop down here to d2 attacking at the
knight and then the rook here to d5 and
I don't really like this move from black
the rook here to d5 we're gonna see the
bishop take and then the pawn recapture
you'd much rather take with your Bishop
here so after the bishop takes the
bishop recaptures this is a much better
position for black this Bishop is much
more active than if it's back here on e7
has a nice little outpost but the reason
that he can't do that and he has to take
with this pawn is because if the bishop
were to come down and take here then all
of a sudden Queen here to c2 is really
really brutal there's no really great
moves that black has to do if let's say
he were to take rook here on e5 that
looks somewhat basic just taking
material on board then all of a sudden
Knight to f6 is just deadly it's
attacking both then the rook and the
Queen but it also opens up the door for
the Queen to come here to h7 and that's
checkmate that's very very bad so you
could see the bishop block here on e4
but then the nice just going to take and
why it's gonna be up just too much
material board if we come back and say
okay instead of the rook taking what if
we just say Queen to e7 that kind of
stops that threat but we could still see
rook take here on d5 after the pond
recaptures the knight can come up here
to f6 it's still very very deadly after
the pond comes here because after that
night all of a sudden 87 that's
checkmate has to worry about that pawn
here to g6 now the knight can just come
up here to g8 take that and then after
it takes pawn takes here this is just
all sorts of trouble of the Queen takes
pawn takes here on f7 and then just
really difficult for black to have to
deal with all these threats on board so
if we come back and say okay you know
what else could we see here well we
could just see the rook take here on d1
we could see the rook take here on d1
maybe take here on e4 that's fine but
then after the Queen takes still
attacking the square here on h7 the pawn
could take the pawn recaptures now the
Queen's gonna come up here to b7 and
just go up too much in material so
that's why unfortunately black can't
take this bishop here he was kind of
forced to take with his pawn instead but
if we come back instead the route coming
down here I just would have been so much
nicer if we were seeing Queen here to f8
not the easiest move to find this it
really looked like it's that active but
actually does a lot and allows black to
really get his dark squared bishop
involved into the game but we see the
bishop come here if the Queen were to
come here to to f8 then we just see
Bishop here to c3 but on board we see
the rook here to d5 Bishop you to b4
after the pawn captures and now white
decides to go ahead and take here and
then the pawn captures here it would be
a mistake if the bishop were to take
here on d5 these small little things
fabiana's putting black in so many tough
situations to take back in correctly
then Queen over here to see to kind of
does the same thing as we talked about
before putting so much pressure this is
just a crazy square that black has to
deal with the bishop here on b1 we could
see now pawn here to g6 but then Queen
here to d2 attacking the pawn on h6 this
is now a big threat as well pawn here to
g5 if you wanted to but now Knight up
here to f6 attacking both the Queen and
the
look if we see the bishop take then the
pond recaptures it's just very difficult
to deal with the Queen can just come
back here to d3 threatening the square
right here so just all sorts of bad
definite nothing really good is gonna
come out of this so we see the pawn
capture here
much better pawn to actually capture
than the Bishop Knight back here to g3
Bishop here to g5 getting it involved
wasn't doing too much back here on e7
also opening up the door for the Queen
to protect this pawn here on e5 white
really wants to start pushing this pawn
up the board and just see if he can call
some havoc on the King side of black
Fabiano now plays rook over here to e1
adding another layer of protection to
this pawn here on e5 also allowing
himself to get the Queen involved and
not have to worry about protecting this
pawn with this Queen now pawn here to g6
queen up here to a g4 attacking this
pawn here on b4 Queen over here to e7
protecting the pawn and then the Queen
over here to d4 nice little series of
moves from Fabiana to kind of set this
position up right here
Fabiano really wants to play pawn here
to e6 pushing that pawn forward has
protection from his rook but also a
discovered attack that's very difficult
for black to deal with black almost has
to play Queen here to e6
unfortunately he threw out that I have
to do anything and he played the
pointless move of pawn here to b6 Bobby
on O quickly plays pawn here to e6
discovered attack black is kind of
forced to block that plays Bishop here
to f6 Queen here to f4 attacking the
pawn here on h6 so we see a pawn here to
g5 kind of stopping that but then Queen
up here to f5 getting ready to bring his
Queen here at sea h7 black has to stop
that plays rook here to a g7 and then
the Queen back here to see - and Fabiana
has kind of orchestrated all of these
Queen moves just getting himself in a
better position making blacks position
even worse all from that very beginning
where he brought his queen up here
brought his queen over here to d4 and
black just was not prepared for it now
the Queen comes here to a c5 Fabiano has
a few options he could just take here on
f7 and this is probably okay after the
rook takes
then we could just see the Queen come up
here to g6 that's gonna be fine as well
Fabiana decides to go ahead and exchange
material off the board that's fine as
well now the knight can come up here
attacking this rook here the route comes
back after the pun takes here on e7 we
do see the game and there's just no way
for black to hold on this board state
this pawn is just too brutal to have to
deal with white just has too much of a
better position so Fabiano wins I've
heard in the past from video say you
know Kevin how would this game possibly
continue well we could see the route
come here to f8 now the rooks wings up
here to e6 attacking both bishops on
board you can start to see how this
losses very very quickly for black maybe
he gobbles up one of the pawns here the
rook takes here rook coming back here if
he wants to because this this Knight can
start to get involved into the game
taking over here on h6 if he wants to
but for me I can just take material on
c5 depending on where the rook is he
could take care on c7 he could take here
on c5 he's you're gonna start gobbling
up material there's no way for black to
do much of anything he kind of has to
stay at bay to protect his his King and
white just has too much powerful
material so all-in-all Fabiana Caruana
takes the first match so it kind of
catapults him into first place we do
have two weeks of chess to go 14 players
round-robin tournament so he's gonna
have to play a lot of games continue the
success but excited to see some of these
players getting ready for the candidates
tournament to come out strong especially
first match in a big tournament not to
play passive not to play for a draw but
actually to go for the win I feel like
that's what he did the entire time
you know black on the other side I felt
like he played pretty well you know
provel made a few mistakes I think and
towards the end didn't didn't really
fully understand some of the big threats
that Fabiano presented to him and all in
all he got the loss there but really
excited about this tournament hopefully
you guys enjoyed this game and look
forward to kind of doing commentary over
the next couple week thanks for watching
I'll see you guys in the next video